je suis d'accord avec vous j'en ai marre
en ce moment de ses émissions là je sais
pas là je trouve qu'en ce moment j'ai
pas à ça c'est une hypocrisie
rock et enregistre et voilà ces
émissions c'est un diamant les monos
marais dont on parle pas que de miss
monde en parle de tous et c'est devenu
chiant franchement je vous dis ah je le
regarde et je ne regarde plus la télé
absents les émissions se portent à
parler les émissions du soir et les
événements sportifs je ne regarde plus
est est parce qu on se fait ch y voit là
je dis la vérité on se fait chier se
passe rien c'est une tannée il se passe
rien il sait bien koala qui arrivent là
j'ai vu là les programmes là de que de
la merde la carie
non mais ils nous servent que de la
merde là franchement les fictions c'est
devenu de la merde les émissions on les
a vu cent fois c'est de la merde en
boite non mais franchement warwickois
mais non mais j'en ai
six cantons mais faire la belle oui on
bouge
l'as saloum
le western du mardi
la premier risque là bas mais on y va là
ça claque non mais sérieux non mais
franchement je vous dire tous les
divertissements deux fois leur france 2
ni divertissement
connais bien je l'aï bien la directrice
des divertissements de france 2 mais
elle est directrice des divertissements
comme moi je suis bouché mais est très
gentil mais elle connaît rien à la télé
c'est d'avoir lu patrick sébastien bien
sûr
j'avais envie d'en parler que les
téléspectateurs elle est très gentil
elle voit elle tente des trucs mais
c'est que tu as plein plan de tous bref
donc tout à france télévisions c'est de
la merde en boite fils de patrick
sébastien ils ont sorti savoir ménages
du l'air le mec est pour mettre
spectaculaire ils n'ont pas fait un
score qui égale celui de patrick
sébastien un
mécène de la liberté la semaine dernière
la liberté mais il faut faire la fête
mais rld les couilles ça rigolait énorme
et le prochain aux emmys jarret
ressemble mais qu'ils arrêtent qu'ils
arrêtent des duos des trios détient déjà
plus que vous le sachiez que c'est que
toutes ces conneries ça coûte une
bataille assez s'il se remet d'un
million non mais c'est ça ça va nous
tuer dit sandy je ne fais l'année
ils s'en foutent c'est que notre argent
c'est l'argent public imagine toi tu
fais partie du gouvernement ont déjà
fait pas partie des coûts vers la france
je sais que le gouvernement il n'en peut
plus trop stylé ville c'est vrai je vous
lis ça on a la même info mais le
président a le goût évident il faut que
les blairer qu'une info moi je vous le
dis j'ai déjà eu des échos comme quoi le
président un peu plus les mairies qui
ont été réélus 1 mais je sais pas mais
en tout cas voilà elle est très gentille
delphine ernotte mais c'est les mecs qui
sont en dessous ils connaissent la télé
comme moi je connais le bowling elle
revient sans déconner encore jeune et
bien voici en voilà bon qu'est ce qu'on
vous n'avez d'autre à dire sur tf1 ouais
franchement ça dort debout away
franchement non mais c'est vrai et même
un animateur qui est sympathie qui le
rendent requis non mais sans déconner il
cessa s'adorent il plus de 1650 lente
inside accord les invités de 50 min
inside i ne servent à rien ils servent à
rien mais cette omission mais cette
émission
c'est quand il a raison l'alizé de 50
minutes inside c'était comme un piquet
il se fait beaucoup de
mes raisons ça promet non maintenant
franchement moi je serai là bas je te
jure je te jetons
c'est plus en direct même depuis en
direct l'émission dance est rien et on
dirait bien mais l'arrêt des charges
aussi à tout le monde pardon c'est que
aujourd'hui le moindre dérapage prend
tellement assez sarments d'ampleur et
bien produit arrive cette fois ici
et non en fait il ça dépend dérapages
ont éclaté mission n'en dira pas non non
non peu plus incroyables m'indigne c'est
quoi un rabais la bouillie pour ne pas
dire un mot plus injurieux des week-ends
quand vous êtes en week-end et que vous
avez envie de regarder j'en suis fait
chier le samedi soir par exemple sur tf1
souvent franchement je vais le dire
c'est de la merde
france 2 trop de tours joie qu'elle est
fiction de france 3 c'est alors la meuf
des films étrangers françois c'est un
génie oui anne méaux et
analyser mais sa noblesse c'est un génie
l extraordinaire sans appel c'est la
patronne de la télé fort voilà efforts
le reste c'est de la merde en bois nuls
et quand vous allez à ma mère me lie à
marmande évidemment et ça c'est pas
possible
non mais et les mecs quand tf1 mais un
prime time de divertissement et qui sont
battues toutes les semaines par des
rediffusions capitaine d'arles où elle
aimait lire même arrêté qui est
lendemain à leur appartient demain nous
appartient s'est battu par un ami qui
est jours à l'époque à l'époque tf1
battu tous les soirs en prime tous les
soirs d'accès par les frères cissé
fermer la chaîne
des mosquées mais même rue que j'aime
beaucoup j'adore usa entre un sens
propre un peu de temps et se passer
quelque chose c'est à madrid que deux à
blanc table pour cirer les pompes de
tout le monde
on éduque et ils ont flingué c'est
ouvrir ce pourquoi ils le flingue mais
moi je les fais des missions blanche je
lui ai dit mais laurent momo l'achète
bolt et sa femme il écoute moi bien moi
j'y vais pas il met un programme qui
fait par exemple 5 millions avant ils
vont te mettre dix minutes et bien sûr
deux bandes annonces et d'autre et la
lutte contre eux et voilà et il va se
retrouver dix minutes en ayant estimé
laurent mois écoute moi bien moi la
chesnaie me fait ça j'appelle le patron
de penser tu écoute moi bien je serai
pas l'antenne ce soir mais tu crois quoi
tu pas eu la tâche n ya pas non mais
attends moi c'est non mais les fous dans
mélo était trop gentil ça rigolait il le
fleuve le gaz ils arrêtent et encore il
s'en sort bien